svelt it's a javascript tool for
building ui components just like react
angular or vue but unlike its peers
would ship a javascript runtime to the
browser to make your code work
svelte is a compiler it converts the
declarative code that you'd love to
write as a developer
into imperative code that works with
native browser apis
as a result you get highly performant
code in a very small package
but most importantly it's the only
javascript framework that's actually
enjoyable to use
we create components in dot spelled
files which contain three main parts
a script for your javascript code which
can also be typescript
a style tag for your css which can also
use a preprocessor like sas and the main
template represented as regular html
but it's no ordinary html it's been
empowered with all kinds of extra syntax
for writing declarative code
need reactive state simply define a
variable with the let keyword then
reference it dynamically in the html
using braces if we want to change the
state we can do that by defining a
function then listen
to an event in the dom with on and bind
the function to it as the handler
now when the value of that variable
changes the component will automatically
re-render to show the updated state
in many cases you'll need to run
conditional logic or loops in your
template
instead of fighting against javascript
functions it empowers you with a syntax
where you can clearly create an if else
statement
or a for each loop when working with a
list now when it comes to
cross-component communication
spelt provides multiple different
strategies for sharing data between
components to pass data from a parent to
child you can use props by adding the
export keyword to a variable and now you
can pass data into this component
and if you have a ton of props you can
use the spread syntax to keep your code
looking fit and healthy
now for more complex component trees you
have a context api just like react
and if that wasn't enough spelt also has
a really nice mechanism called stores
which are like observables that can be
shared anywhere in the component tree
and subscribed to in the template by
putting a dollar sign in front of them
after you've built an awesome ui you can
then use the compiler to convert it to
vanilla javascript
and if you're building a full-blown web
application you can use spelt kit to
quickly implement server-side rendering
routing and code splitting this has been
spelt in 100 seconds
hit the like button if you want to see
more thanks for watching and i will see
you in the next one